it's something that has gone just way
too far and I think the ideological
aspect and the emotional aspect for some
people has sort of just completely taken
over the rational rational and sensible
side of things because if the if the
true issue was just having people being
able to compete in various sports then
there are other ways that you could
handle it rather than that won't affect
women's sports in general I am honored
to have a British women's weightlifting
champion here that is you're the first
first of all you know not a lot of
people can do what I do so yeah yeah not
a lot of people can do it and for those
who don't know what we're talking about
let's roll to the videotape
that is pretty incredible ladies and
gentlemen that is 528 pounds hmm so that
you did and you identified as a woman as
you were doing that left I did I did
yeah so man I save a lot the last month
the last six months have been weird tell
me about how okay so to give people some
context on that video yeah on the 26th
of February 2019 I posted a fee that
video on Twitter with a caption just
saying I keep hearing about how
biological men and women have no I keep
hearing about how biological men have no
strength advantage over women in 2019 so
watch me break the women's deadlift
record without trying and I wrote at the
bottom psi identified as a woman while
lifting the weight so don't be a bigot I
put it out there like I put a lot of
content and tweets out there not
necessarily expecting some sort of huge
global response to it and the whole that
the whole thing went nuts the video has
now got about 1.8 million views it was
covered nationally internationally on
all these different programs all these
different pundits different podcasts
they just blew it just blew the gates
wide wide open at the time that I
tweeted that on Twitter I had 15,000
followers and now got about 117 thousand
as we're recording this so you know 100
hundred K gained largely due to the
catalyst of that video which was weird
but it seems like it touched on a lot of
nerves I didn't realize how wide that
conversation was happening at the moment
so it seems like it was it was timed
perfectly I did it just very flippantly
without huge foresight as to what was
gonna happen but uh yeah it's good to be
known for what you do I guess yeah so I
I don't want to go too far out that so
you but you have a really interesting
family background and where you've moved
and grew up and went to college and all
those things we're gonna hit all that
but somebody watching this must be
thinking well why would someone go ahead
and do that unless they're a trans folk
unless they have some sort of irrational
fear of trans people what what point
were you
there's no irrational fear of anybody I
have no discrimination towards anybody
nor any group at all I think people who
levy that accusation are actually trying
to get away from what the actual point
of the video was which was that we have
got this situation that's happening in a
lot of a lot of different countries I
mean even I think it's might affect the
actual Olympics as well now where
there's this strange debate taking place
about whether or not biological men who
identify as women or who are trans women
should be competing against biological
Natural Born women in various sports
you've seen this happening in everything
from MMA to athletics to weightlifting
to soccer all these all these different
sports and it's one of those things
that's a weird debate to me
because anyone who's just familiar with
basic biology its basic biology yeah
yeah it's not it's not about unfair
discrimination or any kind of hatred or
bigotry towards any group or anything
like that it's just simply saying look
there's a clear distinct physical
advantage here and everyone who kind of
exists in the real world is aware that
that's why you were men in women's sport
to divide it to begin with and always
have been yeah and when you're seeing
this happening I mean in certain sports
you see people come out there and crush
some of these women's yeah well there's
all those pictures of the wrestlers yeah
yeah they're it's it's a it's something
that has gone just way too far and I
think the ideological aspect and the
emotional aspect for some people has
sort of just completely taken over the
rational rational and sensible side of
things because if the if the true issue
was just having people being able to
compete in various sports then there are
other ways that you could handle it
rather than that won't affect women's
sports in general so what we say then
with transgender athletes well firstly
this is interesting because most people
don't actually know this is that most
men's sports divisions are not actually
men's sports divisions they're just open
this is some may actually learned learn
quite
recently so there's not actually a rule
saying this is only for men it's just
that you know so whether you're talking
about I think even things like the NBA
the NHL the made Major League Baseball
they're not actually there's no rule
saying you have to be a man right and
the team as opposed to the WNBA which is
saying we are the women's National Dance
Association exactly so so you could
either that to me the most obvious
things would be either you just have an
open category and anyone who is not you
know any one man woman trans women trans
man whatever everyone anyone can compete
in the men's division as long as they
are within the limits and boundaries of
those when it comes to
performance-enhancing drugs and
testosterone levels and things like that
that would be an existing solution
that's already there or simply if there
are enough athletes I don't know how
many you know transgender male athletes
genuinely exist at that professional
level but if there were you could also
just have another another division and
that way you wouldn't be putting women
at risk or making things unfair for them
and you'd also have anyone who genuinely
just wants to be able to compete and
play anyone can compete yeah play so I
think either of those two solutions
would would make more sense so the
reason why I say I think it's more
ideologically driven is because rather
than doing that people do want to
shoehorn it into the existing categories
despite the fact that there is that
there are large biological differences
there is there is an advantage even if
people were to suppress their
testosterone levels they're still an
advantage it would be like um I mean
maybe a good example would be like a guy
who's using steroids for ten years and
then goes off of them mm-hmm they've
still gotten an advantage over a man
who's never used steroids ever in their
life regardless of the sports is the
ultimate irony of course that actually
by you doing that because you were just
calling out the hypocrisy and nonsense
around this and how it's activists
driven rather than reality driven let's
say that you actually were taking what I
think would be a true feminist position
really right you were taking them the
more Pro woman position do you think
that's fair to say yeah I think I think
fair to say it's weird I think even in
the world of feminism which I'm not not
a part of nor a big fan of in its
modern-day incarnations there seems to
be this issue seems to be quite a big
split that seems to be taking place
there because you've got I guess I don't
know all the terminology but you have
the sort of more gender critical
feminists or the more radical feminists
who are totally opposed to this and then
you have the more liberal feminists who
are saying oh no well trans women are
women so we need to allow them to come
into these spaces whether those are
changing rooms or bathrooms or sports or
anything like that regardless of some of
the potential consequences and it's
actually kind of interesting to watch
from afar and see that split that's play
taking place there but with me you know
I'm very much about fairness and kind of
and it's one of those things that's very
obviously unfair yeah were you shocked
sort of when when this was Catching Fire
and you did a whole bunch of podcasts
and and I think some TV appearances and
things were you shocked the way you got
support from certain quarters that maybe
you didn't think you were gonna get
supported and probably got probably if I
if I've been through this once requires
myself got hate from a lot of quarters
that you didn't think you were gonna get
hate uh or was it obvious to you at that
point I was fairly it was fairly obvious
to me where the support would come from
and where the minor pushback to me to be
honest the pushback was pretty minor you
know in the grand scheme of things when
I say minor I mean millions of people
saw that thing so the minor could still
be several hundred or even thousands of
people but 99.9% of people understood it
got that there was no malice I received
tons of messages actually I mean I do
have followers who are who are trans and
I've got fans who are trans and they
funnily enough none of them took it as
some kind of assault or insult already
that they understood they understood the
point they understood the humor and so I
received actually a lot of messages in
support from me I was probably a breath
of fresh air for them right because I
get emails from trans people when I
discuss discuss issues like this where
people say yeah that that is the reality
I'm
frans but i'm not trying to deny reality
it's an activist driven thing exactly as
you said earlier as opposed to what-what
just regular people want which is just
equality yeah well I think with most
things I think with a lot of groups that
I see I don't think the activists are
very representative of the wider
population so I don't think that trans
activists necessarily truly represent
trans people I don't think that you know
LGBT activists necessarily represent
LGBT people I don't think that black
activists necessarily generally
represent black people I don't think
that feminism really represents the
average woman you know it represents
their own motives and goals and ideas
and stuff like that but I don't think
it's truly a reflection of the wider
groups and and in most of these cases
nobody appointed them to have this
position or this power or to speak to
them but they yell a lot with of that
counts right yeah this is this is the
problem you know see too many people
think that just cuz someone yells a lot
or because they're loud that they are
the voice of reason or representation
which I think you see this across all
these boards and these various
intersectional groups and it's not it's
just not true if you're looking for more
honest and thoughtful conversations
about politics instead of non-stop
yelling check out our politics playlist
and if you want to watch full interviews
on a variety of topics check out our
full episode playlists all right over
here and to get notified of all future
videos be sure to subscribe and click
the notification bell